The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: OK, enough
about knowledge of the past,
be it memory or history.
We are in a very interesting
space-time capsule.
We have the possibility
of imagining the future,
or at least contemplating
more and more about how
one might use even geometry
to associate with minimizing
the obstacles of the future.
And we also have the
capacity to look backwards,
using many techniques, as
showed in these examples.
This should produce a much
richer set of ideas of urbanism
than modernism.
It will depend on the genius of
individual interpreters given
this new scale of things.
What we're not seeing
are overall theories
of urbanism based an
amalgamation of these two
ideas--
forward looking and
backward looking.
Maybe that'll happen.
Maybe we're still too early.
We switch now to a discussion
of the relationship
between public
and private space.
At first glance, the distinction
between private and public
space is simply a
question of the difference
between rights and obligations.
You cannot park
your car on my land,
because I have the
right of ownership.
But when we get to a
parking lot on Mass Avenue,
it's a contestation between two
of us fighting for public use,
for the use of a public--
the available space at any time.
Sometimes we are
very angry that we
are beaten by a car which
has gotten there first,
but we have no rights.
We only have rights
to part if it's free.
In the same way, we
have rights of behavior
in our private world which are
not superintended by the law,
provided we don't hurt
anybody or behave illegally.
But if I grow
marijuana in my garden,
and as long as it's seen
as green space, it's OK.
There are no rules in the
Cambridge Historical Society's
book which says that you're
not allowed to grow marijuana
in your garden.
There probably are other
rules which prohibit that.
There are a number
of other distinctions
between public and
private and have
been used at different times.
I don't want to go into them.
I simply want to look with
you at a number of examples
where the relationship
between public and private
is not so clear and where,
if you take a matrix
and have four headings
to your vertical columns,
the four headings are use,
ownership, access, and meaning.
Let's look at each
of these categories
and see what examples
come to mind.
Under the first, which is use--
use, ownership,
access, and meaning--
Richard Sennett gives
an example, in London,
in the 18th century.
It was impossible for investors
in shipping and in trade
to know the outcome
of of a shipping trip
that they've invested in.
There was no electronic
communication.
It took too long
to write letters.
The letters had to
come by ship, anyway.
So you didn't know
if the pirates had
got hold of the ship that was
carrying silver back to Spain
or whether the ship had
been sunk in a hurricane.
This knowledge was
certainly capable
of being transmitted verbally
through human beings.
So near the docks in London,
a coffee bar grew up.
The coffee bar was
a private entity.
You paid a penny to
enter and sit down.
You weren't able to--
you had to sit anywhere
that space was available.
You couldn't reserve space.
It was frequented by sailors who
had this important information
about their ships.
So the wealthy and
the poor managed
to occupy the same space
because of the importance
of the information.
What became of this place?
Lloyd's of London grew out
of this corner coffee shop.
The important thing is that
an important public set
of transactions
could take place,
but under the shelter of
a private institution.
If we wish to put our body into
public space, we need security.
Security is often provided
more by private institutions
than by public.
30,000 people on
a summer's night
occupy the center of Boston only
if they go to the Red Sox game.
The Red Sox are a
private corporation
with private security.
MIT has its own security force.
Harvard has its-- and the
Christian Science Center--
just going down Mass Avenue,
you would transect a number
of private authorities.
So there's a principle that
the private sector provides
a kind of phenomenological and
actual security for the actions
of public need, such as putting
your body into public space.
For those people who
have criticized--
and they're endless.
Hannah Arendt, for
instance, Richard Sennett
criticized the modern world
as promoting isolation
from the public world--
narcissism, self-preoccupation,
people locked up
in their own private
quarters, fed
by television and
electronic systems
and not hazarding the danger,
if you want to call it,
but the adventure,
which is a better word,
of immersing yourself
into public space.
So public space doesn't exist,
except in Roger Scruton,
the British critic's, argument
that public space only
exists in the street.
All the rest is an affectation
and an unnecessary affectation.
The idea of creating a
public space as a Plaza
is an affectation.
It's true of contemporary
Tokyo, for instance.
Public world exists in the
dense stream of connections
between functions.
There's no tradition of
public meeting space.
Where it's been tried in front
of the tall, new metropolitan
city hall building,
it's a waste of time.
We'll go into the history of
public space in a few minutes.
We still have time.
So if we see that
public use can be
made more appropriate
by private endeavor,
we have a notion
of sharing of use
which has always been
true in urbanism.
The agora, which most of
our arguments for public
communication space rests on,
was a 37-acre piece of messy
mixtures of monuments,
temples, shoemakers,
stoas where philosophers like
Socrates sat and engaged young
men--
not young women, young men--
in discourse, even housing.
This is the space of democracy.
Wycherley, the historian,
writes about it in the same way
that I've just mentioned it as
a highly dense agglomeration
of shoemakers, temples,
monuments, none of which
fit any cardinal pattern.
There is no assemblage of
items in the buildings, which
sit in relation to any other.
This is, in one thesis done here
by a [? Marxist ?] [? smart ?]
student, the result of a kind
of democratic form of rhetoric
which only allowed
people to speak--
that's males and not
women and not slave--
to take part in
discourse through the use
of a particular language.
When it became necessary for
people to meet and debate
propositions later
on, a meeting place
called the Pnyx was created
separate from the agora.
The agora was this mixed domain.
Aristotle rejected that
image of the agora.
For him, a public plane
or public place of meeting
was a clean, absolutely
minimized environment.
I should read you the
quotation from him.
Here-- "The agora in Athens,
far from being architecturally
impressive, was a jumble
of crowded downtown streets
and the regular
open spaces where
shrines and altars, public
buildings and monuments,
stood in the midst of workshops,
market stalls, and taverns.
The agora was the haunt of
the dregs of the populace.
The home of idleness,
vulgarity, and gossip.
For Aristotle, the
ideal public square
were that all commercial
activities and all merchants
and vendors would be exported
to another part of the town.
Nothing in the agora
may be bought or sold.
No member of the
lower order may be
admitted unless summoned by
the" and so on and so on.
So much of Aristotle's view
of the public meeting space,
as opposed to the agora,
the Athenian agora,
has become part of
architectural dogma.
City Hall Plaza rests on
an Aristotelian assumption
that there is something absolute
about prior public space
which is satisfied by whenever
we wish to immerse ourselves
in bedlam.
In a metaphysical
condition, we think of it
as depicting our
public environment
in gracious and hallowed terms.
The curious thing
is the pattern,
the bipolar relationship
between City Hall Plaza
and Faneuil Hall Marketplace.
Faneuil Hall
Marketplace would be
the agora in the ideal
connection between the two.
However, it's not.
It's a singular high,
upmarket phenomenon
totally driven by
market conditions,
at market conditions.
So we start off with a notion of
the public meeting place, which
derives from a unique
setting for democracy
in first century Athens
and has maintained itself
through deviations
under the Romans.
There were no elevated
platforms in the agora
for people to make speeches.
If you spoke, you spoke from the
same plane as everybody else.
The Romans introduced
in the Forum places
for people who were
spokesmen, people
who had particular ability
to make political speeches
or speeches which
are non-political
but of specialized nature.
In the examples I
show in the slides
at the beginning
of next class, you
will see that the traditional--
many of the traditional public
squares in small towns in Italy
were simply based upon
passageways through space, not
cul-de-sacs of space at all.
I spent a year in Assisi, living
in Assisi, documenting the town
and measuring
pedestrian volumes.
The Piazza del Comune
is exactly that space.
I'll show you in
some illustrations.
In the post-telephone
era, the need
for people to
obtain communication
by machine-interposed systems
has become another variable.
What is the most significant
public place built since 1920?
Anywhere?
This is part of an urban
tradition, after all.
If we stopped--
AUDIENCE: But it's really
hard to [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Hm?
AUDIENCE: It's really hard
to say one [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Well, say six.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: The High Line?
[LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART: High Line
is an old train track.
AUDIENCE: Oh, do you
mean from [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN BEINART: No, I don't.
I mean just anything which
resembles a public square.
AUDIENCE: They built one
in Columbia Heights in DC
in the early 2000s that's
been pretty successful.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART:
Rockefeller Center
is by far the best, universally.
It contradicts all the
argument about public.
It's the largest
private investment
in a city in history.
Let me give you a few details.
It's the largest
privately held complex
of its kind in the world.
It's the largest private
building project ever
undertaken in modern times.
It was bought-- it
was leased by John D.
Rockefeller from Columbia
University in 1928.
It was completed-- it was
built between 1930 and 1939.
In 1985, Columbia
University sold the land
beneath Rockefeller Center
to the Rockefeller Group
for $400 million.
The entire complex was purchased
by Mitsubishi Estate in 1989.
In 2000, the current owner
[INAUDIBLE] paid $1.85 billion
for all the buildings.
This is an-- there
could be nothing more
private in ownership
than Rockefeller Center.
It provided the public
with an open space.
It provided the public with
an underground concourse,
shopping concourse.
It added streets to
the number of streets
in the grid in Manhattan.
And yet it's a public space.
So does public space have
to be owned by the public?
I'm looking for examples
of contradictions
simply to make the argument
a little more interesting.
AUDIENCE: Well, there's the
famous court case, a Supreme
Court case, in the suburban
mall in Portland, Oregon.
I forgot the details,
but that's where,
I think, you're not allowed
to have a protest in the mall
even though it functions
as a public space,
because it's private.
So even Rockefeller
has more control
over that space than a space
that actually would be common.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
I don't know about--
certainly, Diego
Rivera's mural--
AUDIENCE: [? Mural ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: --was removed.
And doing this just
before the '39 war.
Germany wanted to invest
in Rockefeller Center
and build something
called Deutsches Haus.
And that was turned down.
So the Rockefellers have played
a very antiseptic attitude
towards politics.
I don't know what the
present status would be.
Security issues at
the moment in America
are probably so
inflamed after Boston
that you would probably
stop anybody carrying
a knapsack for a while.
But to be more serious, I don't
know about the limitations
on public protest in New York.
I should ask somebody.
I don't know of any
history of the restriction
of public protest in New York.
It's a very open city.
AUDIENCE: Well,
with the protests,
they started penning people
in [INAUDIBLE] [? Iraq. ?]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
public [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
and that one, too.
They would--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: There
was that famous--
the day before we invaded
Iraq the second time,
there were protests in
cities all around the world.
And you saw most
[INAUDIBLE] people
were gathering in plazas.
And in New York, they
had you penned in.
They had all the streets blocked
off with the pop-up fences.
It didn't look very open.
JULIAN BEINART: It
raises another question,
which urbanistically,
is difficult to answer.
We have City Hall
sitting on a plaza.
The mayor has said that
he was actually thought
of selling City Hall Plaza--
City Hall.
I don't know about the Plaza.
Do you feel more public
when putting your body
into space in Filene's Basement
than you do in City Hall Plaza?
If association with other
people is the phenomenon which
guides us from a
self-preoccupation
to a sense of being part
of a large human race,
part of the rhetoric
of communication,
stochastics, and so
on, which Hannah Arendt
makes a big fuss of in her
book, The Human Condition,
that we are different
from animals.
I don't go to, nor
do I know anybody
who goes to, Boston City Hall
Plaza on a Sunday morning
to negotiate with strangers.
AUDIENCE: [? You need ?]
[? to go ?] [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: You do--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: --because
you have too little else.
AUDIENCE: But
[? you might ?] [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah, I know--
fair enough.
In Assisi, you would wander
down to the Piazza del Comune
because it's on your path
somewhere else anyway.
It's in the middle
of a small town.
And if there's any action--
secondary, the amount of
private accommodation you've got
is very small.
Why do black kids in Baltimore
play basketball in the street?
Because they haven't
got the space and got
backyards to play
basketball as you can
in your own suburban garden.
So all these connections--
City Hall Plaza should have been
surrounded by dense housing.
Most of the Rockefeller Center
placed in Des Moines, Iowa,
would not be the same as
Rockefeller Center built
on a grid of density plus
income with Fifth Avenue
right adjacent to it and
part of an extraordinary grid
which pumps energy
through all of the system,
much like the system of
reticulation in your brain.
Let's just look at
some other examples.
Under the idea of
control or access,
I pay taxes to maintain
army camps and nuclear power
stations and private domains
which I don't claim access to.
But yet I own a fraction of it.
What is public about me earning
part of the built environment
but not being able
to have access to it?
I have much more access to
shopping environments, which
are largely private
than I do to--
who guarantees access to
all space, independent
of ownership?
This isn't a subject
which Michael Sorkin tries
to attack in his book,
where he terms shopping
centers space be
ageographic, where
there's dissipation of
stable relationships,
of loosening of ties to
any specific place that
is nothing which is
emanating from history.
Everything is ersatz.
The market doesn't
produce any environment
which has the resonance
that is required
for domain of public space.
And lastly, the
category of meaning--
but just before
we leave ownership
is the category of
psychological ownership,
which is very much part of
the habitation of urbanism.
If I had to ask
you, in Boston, what
would we miss more, the Boston
Celtics moving to Sacramento
or City Hall Plaza
being redeveloped?
The one is an absolutely
public phenomenon, especially.
The Celtics are a
private company.
They're only physically in
the sense they play 62--
31 games a year in the town.
But the psychological
ownership, which is a very--
again, we go back
to [INAUDIBLE]----
or not back to him, necessarily.
But we get this
sense that there are
traces of understanding
which we carry
with us as human beings which
are not absolutely contingent.
It's five to two.
Let's just talk a little
bit about meaning.
The federal courthouse in Boston
is an interesting example.
It faces towards
the sea, which is
a foolish kind of notion, facing
to lobstermen in the boats.
The traditional
courthouse in New England
faces towards the
town, to a square,
opposite a church, or
something of this kind.
AUDIENCE: It's really weird,
because the courthouse here not
only faces the sea, but that's
really good prime real estate
that is off-limits.
So it's heavily
secured [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Well, it has
a McDonald's underneath it.
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah,
but underneath it.
JULIAN BEINART:
Well, as part of it.
AUDIENCE: So it's weird to
stand in that little corner,
that little tip, and
look at what they have
and then, at the same time,
see nobody moving around
because of the security
around, surrounding the place.
JULIAN BEINART: It's badly
configured in a number of ways.
But they are private courthouses
in New England, in Boston.
In the State Street
building, there
are courthouses which
are purely private,
where you can settle civil
suits by judges who are retired,
sitting in.
And you have to
agree that you will--
now, what is the difference
between a public courthouse
and a private courthouse in
contemporary [INAUDIBLE]??
The private courthouse is lost
in the assemblage of the State
Street tall building.
You could be going to
visit your accountant,
instead of which you go to
a courthouse, which is not--
all you have to
agree is to listen,
to take the judgment of--
you have the wonderfully
beautiful environment.
It doesn't have the dregs
of the population have
to go to a public courthouse.
I wonder how that would
configure in the [INAUDIBLE]
structure of a town.
OK, I've used the
shorthand system
of trying to connect us
to some of the dilemmas
of public and private life.
The idea of solitude,
removal from the public,
was considered madness
in medieval society.
You were considered insane or
heroic if you went on a trip
without somebody else,
without a group of people.
To build or to maintain
your own private garden
was considered a
very antisocial move.
What caused us, as
a society, to change
from an extreme publicness?
And you read this book
on Socrates in Athens.
You were amazed at the
sense of transparency.
Socrates would be walking
barefoot through the agora,
and a young man would come up
to him and ask him something.
And he'd give a
philosophical answer.
And the young man
would be asking
for where he could buy food.
This intermersing
of the acceptance
of remote speculation about
life and everyday things
is not part of our
domain any longer.
It may be in some places.
Why did we invent solitude?
Let's start with that place.
Think about the answer
to that question.
We are [INAUDIBLE] and
endless architects for not
behaving more in public.
I lived in Assisi for close to a
year, measuring the whole town.
This is a drawing,
an axonometric
based on my measurements, that
some of the texture of part
of the--
part of my purpose
was after being at MIT
as a student in teaching.
I got a Rome Prize to
study pedestrian movement
in a small town.
Next.
This is the Piazza del Comune.
And there's the measurements
of pedestrian flow
at different times of the day.
One of the things
that was interesting
was that there was always this
[INAUDIBLE] the Piazza del
Comune is the central
plaza of the town.
Assisi's a linear town.
I'll just turn on the light
for a second, because--
oh, I'm afraid
you have to-- it's
got this mad system of
turning it off in one place
and turning it on
in another place.
[LAUGHTER]
Assisi's on the slope of a hill.
The town consists of a set
of public spaces linked
across the grain and
along the contours,
with a major Piazza del
Comune in the center.
Because the land
use is distributed
throughout the town,
there's as much chance
of there being a destination
here as destination here.
The volume of traffic
moving this way
through the center
of the town is
the same as the volume moving
that way through the town.
So the center of the
town, in a very dense,
[INAUDIBLE] kind of environment,
is a combination of platforms
at different steepnesses--
Piazza, with the San Rufino,
Santa Chiara, San Francesco,
and so on forming the basis for
the organization of the town
into parishes and
into neighborhoods.
But essentially,
the meeting place
is in a restricted
town in the center.
And serves both as a
passthrough and as a place.
The slide on the left
is my crude attempt
at time-lapse photography
of a burial of a soldier
in the central Plaza.
Next.
I stayed up in the
tower above the Plaza
for many hours of
the day and night
and was struck by the
fact that, when there's
nobody in the Plaza, [INAUDIBLE]
[? years ?] of postmen
delivering mail, it still
seems very well inhabited, as
opposed to when it was
full with the crowd.
It seemed appropriately sized.
Next.
Traditionally, the piazza,
the Italian piazza,
takes its form from a position
of centrality or access,
surrounded by dense
housing environment,
surrounded by a wall.
This is a classic image of it.
This plays out in
different ways.
As the town is a bit
bigger than this one,
this is Il Palio in Siena.
Originally, it is a place for
festivals and for animal games.
Next.
Now, it is a large open
space which, twice a year,
hosts a palio.
And a palio is a kind of
medieval reconstruction
of a ritual.
It's a game in which the
various components of the town
compete in a race.
A lot of money is now gambled.
On the right is an example
of the use of public space
for private use.
This is very typical in
the Italian open space,
where land is leased
from the public authority
by the private--
in this case, a restaurant.
Next.
The palio takes place in
the Piazza Del Campo here.
There are other significant
places in the town.
Just above it is
the great cathedral
and medieval hospital.
People have asked a lot about
the emptiness of City Hall
Plaza.
And there are at
least two theses
which have been written
about it and two competitions
to do something about it.
What is wrong with
Boston City Hall Plaza?
Say something.
AUDIENCE: There's no
real active [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART:
There's no active what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: OK,
there's no reason--
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Hm?
AUDIENCE: The building
[? is ?] [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: The
building is the problem?
Why is the building a problem?
AUDIENCE: [? It's ?] one part
of the [? problem ?] [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: OK, so
we've got a couple of ideas.
The one is there's
not enough housing
density around the square.
That's probably a
good observation.
In a decentralized city, why
do you need a central square?
AUDIENCE: Stubbornness.
JULIAN BEINART:
Stubbornness, yes.
Archivalness-- that this was
a good idea historically,
but it's misappropriated
literally.
It's taken out of
another context
and placed in one
which doesn't serve it.
There have been two attempts
at solutions in competitions.
The one is formal--
that is, to do
something formally.
One of them was to continue
Hanover Street from the north
end through the
Plaza and to advocate
some shopping along it.
Others have proposed no
formal intervention but only
programmatic intervention.
There's one famous one
which puts a baseball
diamond in the square.
AUDIENCE: Also, I think the
biggest difference is that,
in Siena, the space is an
interior space [? and ?]
[? an outdoor ?]
space [INAUDIBLE]..
And here, the space just
meets on [? the sides. ?]
JULIAN BEINART: Well.
AUDIENCE: [? Ties ?]
[? into ?] [? scale. ?]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] City Hall--
there's another
tradition of open space
which I'm not showing.
That is the creation
of open space in front
of important buildings.
In Assisi, there happen to
be small open spaces, plazas,
in front of each major church.
This depends very much on
the quality of the building
that is being addressed
and whether there's
any real significance.
In the Campo del
Siena, the municipality
has paintings from medieval
times of the Comune.
There's a sense that
this place is somehow,
to use a word from
our first class,
that it's somehow centered.
I'm using a word from
the cosmic model.
Centeredness-- it's a
metaphysical concept.
In the case of the Campo,
it is both-- and Assisi--
it is both-- I repeat myself--
it is both an important
functional path to connect
and also a place which can serve
both small and large functions.
Next.
This is the underground
of Rockefeller Center,
the shopping mall and elevators
and new roads and the rooftop
condition, which
was even considered
to have aerial bridges above and
recreation events on the roof.
So in Rockefeller
Center, there's
public space below and above.
Next.
This is the largest--
probably, at its time, the
largest private building
development in history.
I don't know about comparing
it to the pyramids or whatever,
but in modern times, certainly.
It's part-- it's like Assisi.
In Assisi, the square is
part of the structure,
the geometry of the whole town.
In this case, it fits
into a grid system,
which it doesn't try to destroy,
but actually adds roads.
So it's adjacency to Fifth
Avenue, plus it's surrounding
of a high-density
and high-income area,
make this square, again,
a functionally appropriate
commodity, not an attempt
to symbolize something.
Next.
Attempts to-- this
is, on the left,
a project called Urban
Design Manhattan, some 25,
30 years ago, by
a group who tried
to argue that the way
to deal with Manhattan
was to see it as a
three-dimensional system
with vertical connections
private and horizontal
connections public.
The slide on the
right is what you
see of the sky at
intersections in the grid
[? down in ?] Manhattan.
It's an attempt to
argue that there
is a logic to what you see in
the sky between tall buildings.
Next.
The [? muteness ?] of the
departed World Trade Center
and the attempt in Shanghai
to have completely private
activity dominate the scene--
despite all of the
attempts in the competition
and the procedures
of participation
to replace the
buildings on the left,
the building which
is has resulted
is purely the result of the
wishes of the Mr. Silverstein,
the developer.
Next.
The tall building
is a modern icon,
which has often been seen
as having perceptual value,
much like a cathedral that
dominated a medieval town.
The tall building is the--
the attempts to make
them taller and taller--
on the left is a
building in Shanghai.
On the right is Louis Kahn's
attempt to design a [? much ?]
[? lower ?] building
in Philadelphia.
Next.
A Saudi bank building in Jeddah
on the left and the attempt
to make a tall building in
Kuala Lumpur, on the left,
as an Islamic building.
An Islamic skyscraper
is a paradox.
Next.
You've seen this
project on the left.
It's Melnikov's entry into
the Pravda competition
in St. Petersburg,
with a rotating system.
And on the right, the 1922
Chicago Tribune competition--
this is the entry by
Adolf Loos, where--
it's difficult to
explain in simple terms.
But its obviousness
is one of its powers.
Next.
[? There ?] is no legislation
or design of the vertical ends
of tall buildings as a system.
I know of no city in the
world which has an inventory.
This is Houston on the right,
Constantinople on the left.
One might have
thought that somebody
would have had the
idea that the geometry
of the system of tall buildings
would have some significance.
But I don't know
of any [? city-- ?]
if you know of a city, tell me--
which controls the form of
the system of tall buildings.
It's seen as one
of the things that
is not necessary to control.
It's interesting because
it's seen, in many respects,
when you have a river,
and you have green space,
you see the profile of
the city from a distance.
Next.
Tall buildings are often
used to project futurism.
This is on the cover
of an Archigram booklet
on the right and a
Wonder Stories book
on the left, where
the synchronicity
of the transportation
system creates
the dynamic of the city.
Next.
There's another aspect,
concealed aspect,
of the city, much though its
vertical shape is uncontrolled,
so is below the level of
the platform [INAUDIBLE]..
This is a part view of the
workings under Herald Square
in New York.
And on the right is a
Diego Rivera drawing called
Frozen Assets, which argues
that under every city
there are bodies locked
up and dead bodies giving
a kind of macabre picture
of the use of the bottom.
You'll remember a picture
I showed you of travel
in the sewers of Paris--
tourist trips.
Next.
[? Here ?] [? are ?] two
examples in from Manhattan
of the attempt by
new office buildings,
on the Lever Brothers on the
left and the Ford Foundation
on the right, to give
the impression that
they're creating public space.
There's no market for
the space underneath,
as I tried to show in comparison
to Fifth Avenue and Madison,
or Fifth Avenue and Park.
So it's very easy to give up the
ground floor space in an office
building, as it was easy
for Seagrams Building
to sit back in return
for [? higher ?] bulk.
There's no public
space under a tower.
Richard Sennett has written
very critically of this device.
The Ford Foundation puts a
garden inside the building
as if it's a public park.
In fact, it very
curtailed as to its entry.
Next.
Bank in Hong Kong, of
course-- a famous bank where
there's an attempt to
give a sense of public
in the interior.
And the access to the
interior is tightly controlled
by a single escalator.
The whole idea of
this insinuation
is that this represents
a unification
of the work that's being
done in this vertical space.
And yet each group
works individually.
Next.
This is Herman Hertzberger's
insurance company project
in Amsterdam.
No, no sorry-- it's
not in Amsterdam.
It's in-- I'll
think of the name--
where each of the workers
in this insurance company
is allowed to personalize
their own space.
Yet the openness of
the whole structure
depicts a sense of community.
This is the exterior
of the system,
whereby the system stops bluntly
when it leaves the building.
Next.
This is where the conjunction
of public and private
becomes somewhat meaningless.
On the right is Trump Tower.
On the left is Citicorp, the
ground floor of Citicorp,
which has 20 stores and
enormous things going on.
Do you feel public in these
animated spaces, which are
intensely private ownership?
Remember the matrix-- use,
ownership, access, and meaning.
And try always to
use that matrix
to test whether what is private
and what is public about space.
In this case, ownership
is completely private.
Access is public.
Use is public, but
probably oriented
absolutely to private profit.
And meaning is whatever
you want to make of it.
You can feel more
public in the base
of Citicorp Plaza, the
new Citicorp Building,
than you can in City
Hall Plaza in Boston.
Next.
The attempt to
shape tall buildings
with elements of the
decentralized city,
both ecologically and--
it's a bit of a joke.
Next.
From the Wonder
magazine diagrams,
you get this intense--
there are many
visions of Manhattan
which are multiplications
of traffic,
suggesting that automobiles
be on a different-- the trains
on the lowest level,
automobiles above, and including
a rail system, public rail
system, pedestrians on a level
above.
And many levels above
there are pedestrians.
This is an image of the
modern city which is closeted
in a lot of people's minds.
It just doesn't happen.
AUDIENCE: How much was
this vision reinforced
by Fritz Lang's Metropolis?
JULIAN BEINART: A
number of things--
I think Moses King, who did some
of the most wonderful versions
of this-- these are not King's--
portrayed a kind of
utilitarian base to this.
Manhattan was getting to
be so dense and congested
that the reaction was let's use
vertical space to distinguish
between vertical and
horizontal movement.
You can imagine
movies being made.
This is this is probably
suitable for a Batman movie,
extraordinary things are
being-- supernatural events
are taking place.
There's something
supernatural about people
walking on the 20--
up in the sky on the 20th floor
across from two buildings.
The basic rule is that people
are where there's reason to be.
The number of people on the 20th
floor of two office buildings
is too few to generate
any need for connection
at that [? tower. ?] You
come down the elevator,
and you connect to the base.
There are a few
cities in the world
which have developed
enough density, nor do I--
I won't be around, but I don't
project that there will ever
be cities which will
develop significantly
upper-level
pedestrian crossings.
This contradicts much of
the romance with this kind
of world, of architects.
Archigram was based on dense
models of urban interaction,
which seldom take place.
That's why architects
hate suburbia so much.
That's a Catholic statement.
[LAUGHTER]
Next.
On the left is the marathon
in New York and on the right
there are celebrations
after the hostages from Iran
were released and returned.
Archaic relied on space-time
inventions such as rituals
not only to mark space
in particular ways,
as you saw in the example of
Madurai in Southern India.
But in crude form, this
is the same phenomenon,
the bringing together
of people in public
to celebrate a
particular thing--
in the case, a race,
which has meaning which
is meaningless, in the
second, a celebration
to return people after being
captured by a foreign nation.